[Music]
one of most important things for us when
making Joker was to make a very human
story I think sometimes we think of IMAX
as an experience that's made for huge
action movies with these vast landscapes
but a movie like Joker which has at the
heart of it one of the best performances
I've ever seen in a movie is awesome in
IMAX
my mother always tells me to bring
laughter and joy to the world it's
important to know like Joker is not an
action movie the tone of this movie is
probably the best word would be
unsettling and I think that goes
hand-in-hand with the Joker character it
wasn't a typical comic-book movie he
wanted it very realistic it's important
that we connect to Arthur and understand
that he is a very tangible real person
and so it was really important to make a
very tangible and real environment
literally every single sound in the
movie is deliberately thought out
there's light buzz and there's room tone
and there's just mood everywhere we go
and then even when there's quote unquote
silence there's never silence he trudges
his way through a sort of a an invisible
life we tried to connect with him
through the imagery sometimes it was by
putting him very small in a huge
landscape and when he's performing with
the sign early in the movie and then
only choosing to get close to him at
moments
so this movie in a way was sort of made
perfectly for IMAX you're witnessing
this man perform in close-ups and it
fills that screen top to bottom side to
side the expressions of the actors and
the the nuance that they're doing just
comes out better in IMAX it you know we
spend so much effort and so much time in
these immaculate facilities and we make
everything perfect for those screens and
our objective would be that everyone has
a chance to see it in that same level of
perfection of that same technical
quality I know if somebody's seeing in
IMAX they're going to see that and
they're going to see it exactly the way
we wanted it to be seen
[Music]
you
you